[Music]
all right i you know i'll make this the
final question and then elder steve will
close out okay this is a good day i'm a
seven-day adventist i would like to ask
if religion can really save us because
i'm also hearing that question from
others and i also asked myself about
that and i had nothing to say
like
like can it be found in the bible please
enlighten me thank you in advance be
healthy and god
religion saves noah
we're saved by christ
isaiah 45 22 look unto me and be saved
all the ends of the earth acts 4 12
neither is the any other name under
heaven give whereby we must be saved
you're only saved by jesus john 5 48 you
will not come unto me that you might be
saved christ is the savior but christ
has a church
he has a church
acts 7 verse 38 in matthew 16 18 he has
a church the gates of hell shall not
prevail against it he has a church and
the church of christ is the church where
the the righteousness of christ is
uplifted where the law of god is
respected and obeyed through the power
of the holy spirit christ has a church
and so christ takes saved people and
puts them in a church so the church is a
group of people who've accepted christ
who live by the doctrines of christ the
teachings of christ which is genesis
revelation but religion itself cannot
save you because satanism is a religion
and that will save no one in the kingdom
of god are you following me there are
heathen religions there are pagan
religions that do not recognize the god
of heaven and earth the word religion
should not have a magical effect upon
your mind the word truth should affect
your mind the church of god is the
church that produces truth
so yes god has a church but it is christ
that saves but christ saves us to obey
him he saves us he's our savior we obey
him because he's our lord but he's both
at the same time a religion does not
save you because those who said crucify
him were very faithful to their religion
but they tried to kill god they told
pilate we have a law and by our law he
ought to die john 19 verse 7 we try to
use the law to kill the law giver
religion does not save but jesus has a
religion he has a church and he said the
gates of hell shall not reveal against
it because the gates of hell cannot
prevail against truth
amen amen
powerful
friends let's take the side of truth
today
we see that is really the distinguishing
mark
those that are in babylon have rejected
truth while god's people have accepted
and lived by truth and we know jesus is
truth
elder skeet we extend many thanks to you
for your time for grace with your
presence and energy once more we pray
that the lord will continue to shower
you your wife and entire family with his
goodness and his grace and may he go
before you and continue to order your
steps in his word
let me say this quickly
before you go any further
yes it has been demonstrated by research
i don't want to treat research as a god
but research has its place they
demonstrate that when someone adopts a
physician
new light seldom makes a difference to
that person when someone adopts a
position you bring all the new right you
want they will change they usually don't
change this is why sometimes i am so
direct and come across as being so
forceful sometimes you've got to hit
people between the eye with a
sledgehammer of truth to wake them up
not get someone's attention a brick
between their eyes
you know that's why i taught the right
talk sometimes because there's some
people you show them this is black and
they say white because they saw custom
they grow up being told this is why even
though they see black you tell them it's
black they will say white and so
sometimes you've got to be forceful
you've got to grab them by the lapels
and shape them up a little bit in love
to get them to understand you're on the
path to hell can you see that open your
eyes you know jesus said in frustration
why do you not understand my speech even
because you cannot hear my words john 8
43 he seemed baffled they could not
understand what he's saying you know he
tells the israelites why will he die
ezekiel 33 why are you dying
and so sometimes you're going to speak
to me why are you keeping sunday when
you have no bible verse why do you keep
doing that why won't you change and keep
god's sabbath day the seventh day why
and so sometimes you've got to knock
people up against the head in love of
course to save them so that's why
sometimes i'm a little forceful it's not
because i'm harsh i'm not harsh tall i'm
a nice man says indonesia i'm sure
you'll say it then but sometimes you're
going to be forceful for the salvation
of people's souls and i'm finished now
god bless you my lovely sister god bless
and all those who are part of the
program and who
listened amen amen thank you so much
elvis yes indeed you are a very very
nice man god bless you god bless you god
bless you
to those of you that have been watching
online i see rose mentioned you before
thank you for tuning in marcus steele
from trinidad and tobago
uh who else is here yes
bossier abel from nairobi kenya also
mark alex from nairobi kenya thank you
all for tuning in and joining two
brother kevin gomez thank you so much
for asking those questions adding the
commentary keeping the fire going sister
stacy and i know you'll be doing our
closing prayer so thank you in advance
for doing that and for moderating the
chat to my mom as always thank you for
your support prayers and counsel for
sharing this live those of you that are
watching feel free to share like and
subscribe so you are notified whenever
we go live and so that the word of god
can reach near and far
now you mentioned kenya
the only country mentioned so let me say
greetings to all my kenyan brothers and
sisters who are listening and you scan
you a lot maybe one day god will open
the way with this pandemic me to return
but god bless kenya all kenyans and any
other country represented or listening
may god bless you in your countries
[Music]
you